exam season is here if you're in the UK
that means you'll be taking GCSEs AAS
levels or a levels very soon and if
you're taking exams wherever you are the
very best of luck to you if you are
anything like I was however by this
point you are probably sick to death of
the material and you're probably
desperate finding a way to revise but
also not be bored out of your mind well
for the next several weeks I'm going to
be streaming on my twitch channel
twitch.tv/esa Simon Clark going through
old exam paper the point in doing this
isn't a speedrun it isn't trying to show
off it is to try and teach by looking
through specific questions so in
answering a given question I will
explain what I'm doing at every step of
the way I'm going to talk a bit about
the more general theory perhaps talking
about some stuff that you know is beyond
the syllabus or stuff that I did at uni
what I hope to do is provide a couple of
hours a week where you can relax enjoy
and actually get some revision done on
the sly or potentially you could just
you know have me minimized on your
screen where you're watching other
people on Twitch and then put me up and
pretend you're revising I'm okay with
that I have actually been doing this for
several months now I normally stream on
Sundays playing Kerbal space program and
more recently Skyrim and then on
Wednesdays I've been going through past
papers we've done physics Olympiad
papers math challenge papers a level
GCSE papers from around the world to
give you an idea of what to expect here
are some highlights I know neither
missing it's been a while since we've
seen the plebeian calculus but it is
back ko
that's the clip Jesus I'm bleeding quite
a lot Quinn I just come to the basic
maths oh no no no well there goes the
spacecraft I've rotated the paper we've
never before been done in palma street
rotate the board it's not expecting this
to go smoothly is this in any way
cuz I'm either right wrong twice ow
just turn on the trike so we now have
two bandages on me
sneezing ASMR I've never seen the
scientists in their comfortable taste
like twitch subs so if you like maths
and physics and you like memes come and
check out my twitch they'll be linked
down there in the description make sure
you follow the channel to be notified
when I go live and also keep an eye on
my Twitter that's at Simon ox fizz to
know when they're extra stream is being
planned I really hope to see you on one
of these streams it's so much fun to do
it I love the community that's formed
around the streams already and we're
excited to expand it to all you lovely
people from this channel so go follow
twitch.tv/esa i am as in prime you could
always put me a cheeky twitch prime sub
plug plug plug plug plug plug but most
importantly I hope to see you at some of
these revisions dreams we're gonna have
a lot of fun over the next couple of
weeks
best of luck to those of you taking
exams and I'll see you on Twitch
[Music]